nous voulons une agriculture performante
innovantes
cela passe par l'enseignement agricole
marion zalay qu'en pensez vous comment
voyez vous cette formation à l'avenir
pour nos jeunes
merci beaucoup merci de votre invitation
tout d'abord je très honoré d'être à
cette table ronde environné environné
par autant de compétences est évidemment
de parole importante
je voudrais simplement je me présente
donc j'ai été une ancienne directrice
générale de l'enseignement et de la
recherche il y a quelques années
j'espère que christian m'épargnera
s'effacer si elle est gardée revêt en me
rappelant que c'était il ya très
longtemps c'était y'a pas si longtemps
d'ailleurs
voilà tout d'abord toujours voilà donc
je voudrais juste vous apporter ce ce
témoignage sur un élément qui a beaucoup
compté dans l'histoire de l'agriculture
parce que les jeunes agriculteurs
certains sont là le président n'est pas
là mais il pourrait en témoigner mieux
que moi
les jeunes agriculteurs et les jeunes
agriculteurs et l'enseignement agricole
c'était une très longue histoire
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas faire injure
au ni ni des voiliers cette histoire que
de voir dans l'enseignement agricole en
tout cas un des facteurs clés à la fois
des évolutions importantes de
l'agriculture et puis évidemment de
beaucoup de ses succès dans
l'agriculture d'ailleurs enfin
l'enseignement agricole d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus qu'accompagner ces
mutations et ses étapes importantes de
la modernisation du métier d'agriculteur
a été a su préparer les agriculteurs
préparer les générations à ces mutations
indispensables que à la fois l'évolution
du monde
les réformes les unes après les autres
ont imposé comme rythme et d'adaptation
à une à une profession dont on saluera
jamais assez je crois cette capacité de
rebondir cette capacité à se projeter
cette capacité à réinventer son métier
c'est pour ça que l'humeur générale et
je réponds à votre question je ne suis
pas très inquiète pour l'avenir parce
que je crois que l'agriculture à en
elle-même et au delà de tous les appuis
de tous les soutiens celui de la société
celui
je dirais des pouvoirs publics celui de
l'innovation et de la recherche mais
qu'elle s'est trouvée en elle-même les
ressorts et je crois que les témoignages
qu'on a eu ce matin montrent à l'envi
que il en faut beaucoup plus pour
décourager ceux qui tous les tous les
jours son nom leur exploitation alors le
l'enseignement l'enseignement agricole
il a su donner il a su il a su préparer
des générations entières à ces métiers
et c'est un enseignement qui est tout à
fait atypique je crois que c'est
important on s'est habitué à voir
l'enseignement agricole c'est quelque
part une incarnation aussi une certaine
forme d'enseignement rural mais on
oublie parfois le caractère totalement
original je dirais même cet ovni dans le
système éducatif puisque c'est le seul
enseignement à côté l'éducation
nationale qui d'une part et sont proches
son budget son budget qui d'autre part
n'obéissent qu'à un seul mise qui n'est
pas celui de l'éducation et qui va de la
4e jusqu'au diplôme d'ingénieur et/ou
doctorat donc la question aujourd'hui
n'est pas de savoir si l'enseigné mois à
un avenir quelque part c'est une
question très secondaire sauf peut-être
pour le ministère de l'agriculture
la question est de savoir si
l'enseignement agricole est aujourd'hui
en capacité non pas de préparer les
agriculteurs au monde tel qu'on voudrait
qu'il soit mais au monde tel qu'il est
il ce sujet là évidemment est un sujet
important est un sujet de fond quand je
parle d'enseignement agricole d'une
manière générale et je pense que vous
l'aurez compris semble bien évidemment
la recherche surtout la recherche
appliquée à la clé d'ailleurs les plus
la profession agricole contribue
beaucoup mais évidemment aux innovations
et à tout ce qui permet d'avoir je
dirais la diffusion sur le terrain et
l'appropriation des nouvelles techniques
alors dans les dents les temps très
troublé que nous vivons en ce moment que
l'agriculture vit en ce moment avec des
campagnes qui sont évidemment très
secoués je pense que voilà les images
les images et l'émotion qui je dirais
filtre part à la fois les médias les
témoignages qu'on a entendu je pense le
démontrent à l'envi bien oui je pense
que l'enseignement agricole a une fois
encore la capacité non pas seulement de
préparer mais d'anticiper les
adaptations à la fois des agriculteurs
des exploitants agricoles mais aussi des
filières alors évidemment à certaines
conditions
la première condition c'est qu'il trouve
une fois encore les ressorts pour donner
les clés de la performance aux
agriculteurs dans un monde où la
compétition contrairement à certain
nuage nucléaire ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières de notre pays à la condition
aussi qu'ils sachent être le relais à la
fois de la diffusion de l'explication
mais aussi de l'appropriation des
nouvelles technologies sans lesquelles
rien ne se fera ça veut dire évidemment
de la robotique d aide à la décision
ça veut dire évidemment cette
agriculture de précision où le pilotage
la géolocalisation toute la technologie
de pointe permet aujourd'hui aux
agriculteurs de façon performante d'être
les meilleurs utilisateurs ou en tout
cas de faire d'utiliser leurs intrants
de la façon la plus optimale possible
et évidemment en surveillant leur
production au plus près du terrain et de
la réalité je dirais agronomique des
choses ça suppose aussi que
l'enseignement agricole
il continue
d'être professionnalisant alors à cet
égard devrait raconter une petite
histoire très brièvement je vous rassure
quand j'ai pris mes fonctions à la tête
de la direction générale de
l'enseignement et de la recherche
j'ai voulu savoir beaucoup de questions
se posaient dans l'enseignement son
adaptation aimait beaucoup de évidemment
de revendication de part et d'autre et
j'ai voulu savoir si aujourd'hui c'était
pas clair en tout cas si l'enseignement
agricole était véritablement adaptée aux
besoins des agriculteurs et donc j'ai
demandé au président des gia de
m'envoyer un des membres de son bureau
en essayant de me choisir celui qui
était plus récemment installée donc je
vais en avoir il m'en a envoyé 1
c'était pas le plus c'était pas
d'ailleurs le plus mauvais puisque un an
plus tard je l'invitais au congrès des
proviseurs avec sa nouvelle casquette de
président des gia pour expliquer à tous
les proviseurs de lycées agricoles ce
que la profession en ce que les jeunes
en tout cas attendez d'eux et je lui ai
dit vous êtes installé depuis six mois
quel regard vous portez sur votre
enseignement celui que vous avez reçue
et qui vient de se concrétiser par un
diplôme il ya quelques semaines et il me
dit mais je me suis demandé depuis
combien de temps mais enseignants mais
formateur n'avait pas mis le pied dans
une exploitation agricole
voilà j'étais là depuis quelques
semaines et j'ai dit au ministre je
pense ça serait bien qu'on fasse des
assises de l'enseignement agricole
c'est ce qu'on a fait et effectivement
on s'est efforcé d'inscrire dans les
propositions en tous cas les décisions
qui avaient été qui avait été formulée
par le ministre n'ont pas cette
obligation c'est toujours très compliqué
mais en tout cas cette incitation cette
incitation forte que quand les gamins ou
les ados sont en stage eh bien peut-être
pas à tous les stages mais de temps en
temps que les enseignants aïe je dirais
actualiser leurs connaissances quelque
part sécularisée
leur métier soit pas été tout à fait
simple je ne vous cacherai pas et puis
je pense que c'est l'enseignement
agricole il doit aussi se défaire d'un
certain nombre je dirais de quelques
convictions ou de quelques credo un peu
poussiéreux qui disparaissent mais qui
parfois sont encore présents qui est
celui des mots qu'on ne peut pas
prononcer donc on parlait de on parlait
de l'entreprise
on parlait de oui on parle de
l'entreprise on parlait d'un certain
nombre de choses une autre anecdote le
directeur général l'enseignement et de
la recherche doit en tout cas à la
possibilité de re lire tous les
documents d'examens tous les sujets qui
sont proposés pour tout l'été pour tous
les diplômes que distribuera en tout cas
de l'enseignement agricole et du
ministère de l'agriculture et donc je
relise tout ça ce qui représente un gros
boulot et puis je tombe sur un sujet qui
me pose un peu de difficultés puisque on
demande aux élèves aux candidats aux
baccalauréats professionnels
si le productivisme et est un atout ou
un inconvénient pour le métier d'acteur
je fais venir le doyen de l'inspection
de l'enseignement bémol puisque ce sont
les inspecteurs qui rédige les qui
rédige les sujets il lui demande de
m'expliquer le sujet et ce qui l'attend
comme réponse il suffit tout ça j'ai dit
mais ça c'est pas le productivisme
c'est la productivité alors
effectivement il voit là et donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
très important je pense que
l'enseignement agricole aujourd'hui il a
toutes les capacités pour le faire
il a toutes les capacités pour apporter
des réponses il a toutes les capacités
pour porter l'innovation savoir la
diffuser sur le terrain il a aussi toute
la capacité et pas seulement pour la
culture mais aussi pour le monde rural
on a rappelé ça a été dit tout à l'heure
mais que je le ferais ça a été dit par
eric woerth aujourd'hui le sentiment de
délaissement et d'abandon de des milieux
ruraux
aujourd'hui l'enseignement agricole peu
avec l'agriculture reste et ce pôle
d'animation de vie sociale et économique
de toutes nos régions de tous nos
territoires
merci pour ce beau commentaire je crois
qu'on peut vous applaudir parce que
l'enseignement agricole est
indispensable pour pour nos jeunes voilà
nous clôturons cette première table
ronde sincèrement merci beaucoup pour
les questions on a beaucoup de retard
donc on va passer à la deuxième table
ronde qui est toujours une thématique
agricole et après la table ronde
on enchaînera les questions s'ils n'en
sortira pas merci beaucoup on revient
que l'agriculture c'est pour nous
important ce sont des chefs d'entreprise
l'économie agricole sera la première
économie en france et en europe
merci à vous pour cette belle table
ronde et on passe à la deuxième